- Do you know what the
triangle said to the circle?
"You're pointless."
(laughs)
Trump, Mueller, Cohen, Manafort,
Putin, Flynn, Trump
Jr., Comey, Rosenstein.
You've heard of all of these names
a billion times over the past year,
and by now, you probably know
that the Justice
Department is investigating
Russian attempts to interfere
in the 2016 election to
help Donald Trump's chances,
and to hurt Hillary Clinton's chances,
but the truth is that this investigation,
which is being led by Robert Mueller,
a former head of the FBI,
has so many subplots and so
many major and minor characters
that it's starting to feel a little bit
like watching Game of Thrones.
You kinda sort of have a vague memory
that the guy talking on
your TV screen is important,
but you can't totally place him
or remember exactly
why he matters so much.
Sidebar, it took me years
to get the whole Bronn
versus Bran thing down.
The former is the guy who pals around
with Jaime and Tyrion Lannister.
The latter is the son of Ned Stark.
Boom, ha-ha, nailed it.
10 out of 10.
Eight seasons in.
With nearly 200 criminal
counts already brought
against defendants so
far in the Russia probe,
even old George R. R.
Martin would be confused,
so here's my attempt to
make sense of it all,
and I'm gonna do it in
just under 30 minutes.
This whole thing started
because George Papadopoulos,
a relatively minor foreign
policy advisor to Trump,
bragged to an Australian diplomat
while out drinking in London in May 2016,
as one does, that the Russians
had dirt on Hillary Clinton.
A couple months later,
the website Wikileaks
started publishing emails
that had been stolen
off the Democratic National
Committee's servers.
The Australians then alerted
their American counterparts
to what Papadoloupos had
said all the way back in May.
The FBI opened an investigation
into Russia's possible attempts to meddle
in the 2016 presidential election.
That's the origin story.
Mueller comes into the
picture in May 2017.
He's appointed by deputy
attorney general Rod Rosenstein
to take over the FBI
investigation as special counsel?
Why?
Because, a week earlier,
Trump had fired James
Comey as FBI director.
Comey had been leading
the Russia investigation,
and there was lots of talk
that Trump was trying to
end that investigation
by removing Comey, so putting Mueller,
a registered Republican
who had been appointed
to the FBI by both a Democratic
and a Republican president,
in charge of the investigation
was regarded as the best way
to get to the bottom of all
of this, whatever this was.
Now, Mueller's task was both
simple and pretty broad.
Number one, to investigate
Russian interference in the election,
number two, to look into whether anyone
on the Trump team
colluded with the Russians
to help get their candidate elected,
and number three, quoting from the memo
that established the special counsel,
quote, "To prosecute federal crimes
"arising from the investigation
of these matters."
Now, let me take a moment here
to make an important note.
No collusion, I repeat, no collusion.
I kid, but not really.
The president's almost manic insistence
that there was never any collusion
between him and the Russians is indicative
of the broader efforts by
Trump and people close to him,
Rudy Giuliani, I'm looking at you,
to spin this whole probe into nothingness,
but facts are facts,
and the facts are these.
192 criminal charges have been brought
by Mueller against 36 people and entities.
Seven people have pleaded guilty,
and many of those have flipped,
cooperating with the investigation,
including the aforementioned Papadopolous,
deputy campaign chairman Rick Gates,
former national security
advisor Michael Flynn,
and Trump's longtime lawyer
and personal Michael Clayton
figure, Michael Cohen.
The vast majority of
that group pleaded guilty
to lying to federal authorities,
or Congress, or both about the nature
and extent of their
contacts with the Russians.
Flynn, for instance, lied
about his conversations
with Russian officials during
the presidential transition.
Cohen lied to Congress about
when he stopped talking
to the Russians about the possibility
of building a Trump Tower Moscow.
Look, you get the picture.
What we know for a fact
is that lots of people,
some very close to Donald Trump,
others merely in his campaign periphery,
have lied about their
contacts with Russia.
The other fact that we know for sure
is that Russia actively
sought to interfere
in the 2016 presidential election
to help Trump and hurt Clinton.
How do we know that?
Because, no matter what
Donald Trump says or tweets,
the US intelligence community
unanimously confirmed
that fact in early 2017.
What we don't know is, well, a lot.
We don't know whether or not
Mueller has found any evidence
that someone or someones
in the Trump campaign
colluded with the Russians.
We do know that Donald
Trump Jr., Jared Kushner,
and Manafort met with the
Russians in June 2016,
lured by the promise of dirt on Clinton,
but that's not definitive proof of much.
We don't know whether or not
Mueller has found any evidence
that Trump tried to obstruct justice
by firing Comey to get in the way
of the Russia investigation.
We do know that Comey said
in his sworn testimony
to Congress that Trump asked him
if he could find a way to let this go,
in reference to the
investigation into Flynn.
We also don't know when
Mueller is planning
to wrap this all up.
Trump and his Republican
allies have been subtly
and not so subtly exerting public pressure
on the special counsel to
bring this all to an end.
Mueller has, to date,
completely ignored that pressure campaign.
In fact, he's been almost totally silent
since being appointed as special counsel.
Hell, he's barely been seen in public
except for that one time he was sitting
at the airport waiting
for his gate to be called.
We've all been there, Bobby.
Do your friends call you Bobby?
Where does all of this leave us?
It leaves us with a lot of smoke,
like, so much that you can barely see
right in front of you,
and a president who asks
us all to ignore it,
insisting that he is the real victim here.
That is the point.
The Point comes out twice
a week every single week.
Make sure to check out new episodes
every Tuesday and Thursday.